as we'll see in this video and in others
the roots of a lot of the current a lot
of the current disagreements in the
Middle East and a lot of the conflict in
the Middle East can actually be traced
back to World War one and I realize this
is an incredibly touchy subject that
there are people who have very strong
feelings on either side of it and my
goal here is to really give give my best
my best attempt at what really happened
but I encourage you to to doubt any of
this and look it up yourself and come
frankly to to your own conclusions so
let's rewind back to October of 1915 or
1915 in particular the British were
already at war with the Ottomans this is
a reminder of some of what happened in
1915 the Gallipoli campaign by the end
of 1915 it was pretty clear that this
was a disaster for the Allies the
Ottomans were able to fend off the
Allies they were in retreat the the
British were able to fend off the
Ottomans when they tried to attack the
Suez Canal in 1915 so this is the
background you could imagine that the
British are are are eager to get any
other allies that can in their battle
against the Ottoman against the Ottomans
and in particular they're eager to get
the help of the Arabs who have been
under the rule of the Ottomans for
hundreds of years and so that's the
backdrop where you have this
correspondence between the High
Commissioner in Egypt the British High
Commissioner Sir Henry McMahon and the
Sharif of Mecca Hussein bin Ali who had
his own aspirations to essentially be
the king of an independent Arab state
and they kept going back and forth from
mid 1915 to early 1916 talking about
what the state could be obviously the
British want his support if once that
wants him to lead a revolt against the
against the Ottomans and he's already
articulated kind of the boundaries for
four-state that he would like to see and
so that gives us a context for this
correspondence in October of 1915 this
is from Sir Henry McMahon to Hussein it
is with great pleasure that I
communicate to you on their behalf the
British government's behalf the
following statement which I am confident
you will receive with satisfaction the
two districts of marsinah and Alexandria
and portions of Syria lying to the west
of the districts of Damascus Homs Hama
and Aleppo can
not be said to be purely Arab and should
be excluded from the limits demanded so
this is referring to the limits that
Hussein bin Ali had demanded in previous
correspondence with the above
modification so just that region right
over there this right over here is
marsinah
Alexandretta this is Hama Homs Damascus
so really what he's referring to is this
region the west west of those of those
cities right over here so he's saying
look this is you can't really consider
this to be purely Arab I'm going to
exclude this out of the boundaries of
this potential independent Arab state
with the above modification and without
prejudiced or existing treaties with
Arab Chiefs we accept those limits we
accept those limits as for those regions
lying within those frontiers where in
Great Britain is free to act without
detriment to the interest of our ally
France so as long as I'm not getting in
trouble with France I'm empowered in the
name of the government of Great Britain
to give the following assurances and
make the following ish and make the
following reply to your letter subject
to the above modification so taking this
part out Great Britain is prepared to
recognize and support the independence
of the Arabs in all the regions within
the limits demanded by the sharif of
mecca
so essentially included all all of this
region without and actually much beyond
what I'm showing here kind of
present-day Syria Jordan Iraq parts of
present-day Saudi Arabia so all of that
is essentially the British are saying
yeah we're going to allow you to to have
that an independent state their Great
Britain will guarantee the holy places
against all external aggression and will
recognize their inviolability I am
convinced that this declaration will
assure you beyond all possible doubt
beyond all possible doubt of the
sympathy of Great Britain towards the
aspirations of her friends the Arabs and
will result in a firm and lasting
alliance the mediate results of which
will be the expulsion of the Turks from
the Arab countries and the freeing of
the Arab peoples from the Turkish yoke
which for so many years has pressed
heavily upon them so this actually does
help to convince the Arabs to rise up
against against the Turks against the
Ottoman Empire they play a significant
role in the Palestine campaign they rise
up in June of
19:16 now the video that I did on the
Palestine campaign I got several
comments of people being cynical about
about Britain's intentions and it does
look like the British the were indeed
cynical TE Lawrence famous for Lawrence
of Arabia who is often depicted as kind
of this this mystical fellow this guy
who had this kinship with the Arabs
his actual correspondence with the
British government actually do show that
he he did have a kind of a he was doing
I guess in the words of George W Bush a
little bit of strategic he had a more
cynical view of this relationship with
the Arabs this is some correspondence
that he wrote in early 1916 so right at
the same time that all of this was going
on so this is he's referring to a
possible Arab revolt or Hussein's
activity activity Hussein's activity
seems beneficial to us because it
matches with our immediate aims the
breakup of the Islamic bloc and the
defeat and disruption of the Ottoman
Empire assuming he didn't really talk
about this this has been one of the or
the British didn't talk about that when
they were talking to Hussein if we can
arrange that this political change shall
be a violent one we will have abolished
the threat of Islam by dividing it
against itself and it's very hard there
will then be a khalifa kind of a seed of
Islam in Turkey and a Khalifa and Arabia
in theological warfare so this is TE
Lawrence I got this from the golden
warrior the life and legend of Lawrence
of Arabia so even this somewhat
portrayed as a heroic figure was was
doing things in very kind of strategic
strategic terms now to make things worse
for the Arabs while the British were
trying to convince them to revolt they
were also in secret negotiations with
the French on how they would divide the
Middle East if they were to if they were
able to beat the Ottomans and at this
point in the war the British were
already making some progress in
Mesopotamia but they really hadn't
really started on the Palestine campaign
right here so this was all conjecture
but the British representative was Sykes
the French representative was picot this
was done with the consent of the
Russians you didn't have a revolution in
Russia as of now and so in early 1916 in
May this kind of agreement was concluded
a secret agreement you have the Sykes
sykes-picot picault agreement it's
secret let me write that it is a secret
agreement between Britain between
Britain and France and essentially
they're carving up the entire Middle
East between them this blue area right
here this would be occupied by the
French part of eastern Turkey or
modern-day eastern Turkey would be given
to the Russians the British would would
be able to occupy would occupy southern
Mesopotamia essentially insuring kind of
protection of of the oil that is coming
out of Persia oil is becoming more and
more of a relevant factor and kind of
global power and then you have these two
protectorates right over here which in
theory could be independent or an
independent Arab state or two
independent Arab states under the
protection under the let me put that in
quotes because Protectorate is always
not as nice as it sounds under the
protection of the French or the British
which means that you're an independent
state but we will protect you in case
anyone wants to invade the reality of
protectorates is that it usually
involves the people doing the protect
during the people who are doing the
protecting have all of the the real
power and all of the real influence and
the sykes-picot agreement also gave this
little carve out to Britain so they
would have access to the Mediterranean
and Palestine or the Roman Kingdom of
Judea this is carved out as kind of a as
a separate a separate international
property something that would be
administered by by multiple states and I
guess the argument would be is this is
where the holy lands are multiple
religions have some of their holiest
sites within here and so they carved it
out like this and once again this is all
in secret they obviously don't want the
Arabs to find out because they're about
to convince the Arabs to join in a
revolt against the Ottomans now to make
things and once again this was all in
secret up to this point in 1916 when it
was all agreed on and then you forward
to nineteen 1917 where we have the
famous Balfour Declaration so this right
over here is the Balfour Balfour
Declaration and it was essentially a
letter from from the Foreign Secretary
of the UK Balfour to Lord Rothschild who
was a very Leo the leading British
citizen a lead
member of the Jewish community and in it
he writes dear Lord Rothschild I have
much pleasure in conveying to you on
behalf of His Majesty's Government the
following declaration of sympathy with
Jewish Zionist aspirations which has
been submitted to and approved by the
Cabinet His Majesty's Government view
with favor the establishment and
Palestine of a national home of a
national home for the Jewish people and
will use their best endeavours to
facilitate the achievement of this
objective it being clearly understood
that nothing shall be done which may
prejudice the civil and religious rights
of existing non-jewish communities in
Palestine or the rights and political
status enjoyed by Jews in any other
country I should be grateful if you
would bring this declaration to the
knowledge of the Zionist Federation
signed signed Arthur Balfour and here
he's not explicitly saying and they're
being very careful here he's not saying
we're supporting a state for the Jewish
people but he's saying he's supporting
the return a national home for the
Jewish people but at the same time he's
saying that it being clearly understood
that nothing shall be done which may
prejudice the civil and religious rights
of the existing non-jewish communities
in Palestine needless to say you could
imagine that this kind of is is making
the the Arabs fairly uncomfortable on
one side it seems based on some of the
McMahon Hussein correspondences that
were you know especially in 1915 that
that they were being promised a kind of
an independent Arab state which included
much of this territory but at the same
time in the Balfour Declaration the
British were promising to a kind of a
Jewish Diaspora that they could have a
homeland there and it might one day who
knows it might one day turn into some
type of a state and to make the Arabs
even more uncomfortable this was in
November 2nd 1917 by the end of November
you have to remember that 1917 you first
had a revolution in Russia the Tsar is
overthrown in February and in March of
1917 in October the Bolsheviks take over
they they want to get out of the war
they don't like all these secret deals
not clear that they would even get what
they what they were entitled to in these
secret deals and so they actually
release all the entire text of the
sykes-picot agreement they released this
on the same month you have the Arabs
and the Ottomans who and the Ottomans
were very happy to see this because it
kind of would would undermined the Arabs
kind of belief and maybe supporting the
Allies but in one month you have the
Arabs finding out about the Val 4
declaration which was a public
declaration and then later that month
because of the Russian release of it the
the formerly secret sykes-picot
agreement so it makes them very or at
least a little bit more suspicious and
so you can imagine this this the the the
British Empire trying to have it both
ways to kind of have support from the
Jewish Diaspora while at the same time
have support from the Arabs in the
revolt against the Ottomans would lead
to very significant conflicts over the
decades to come regardless of which side
of the issue you fall on a lot of the
seed is happening right around now right
around World War one and this is has
been admitted by the British government
this is right here this is this was the
then secretary or Foreign Secretary Jack
Straw UK foreign secretary in 2002 this
is a statement he made to the New
Statesman magazine in 2002 a lot of the
problems we are having to deal with now
I have to deal with now he's a foreign
secretary our consequence of our
colonial past consequence of our
colonial past the Balfour Declaration
and the contradictory assurances and the
contradictory assurances which were
being given to Palestinians in private
at the same time as they were being
given to the Israelis again an
interesting history for us but not an
honorable one and this is really just
the beginning as we'll see in future
videos as we go to the interwar period
the British kind of go back and forth on
on this issue over over and over again
but needless to say it's led to a very
messy situation in the modern Middle
East